partir sur le terrain tout de suite où
des bombardements ont lieu depuis ce
matin un petit peu partout à travers
l'ukraine hazard porridge à au sud-est
du pays on va retrouver tout de suite
julien scheyder nos envoyés spéciaux
julien bonsoir la russie promet de ne
pas blesser les civils pourtant il ya
déjà des dizaines de victimes quelle est
la situation là où vous vous trouvez
oui effectivement il ya eu des dizaines
de victimes qui auraient été recensés du
côté de d'odessa et aussi à l'échelle de
tout le pays mais il est vrai que pour
l'instant ce sont surtout des positions
militaires qui ont été visés pour le cas
de mario paul nous ne trouvions encore
ce matin lorsque nous avons entendu des
déflagrations sur le moment de très
fortes déflagrations sur le moment il
était impossible de savoir quelle était
l'origine et surtout si le missile
venait de la mer ou du désert et surtout
il était impossible de savoir quelle
était la cible sur le moment quelques
heures plus tard nous avons appris qu'il
s'agissait d'une base militaire et aussi
surtout d'un site des défenses aériennes
ukrainien d'autres sites militaires
ukrainiens ont été visés notamment plus
au nord de marioupol akram à tort ce qui
se situe tout près de ce qu'on appelait
encore jusqu'à hier la ligne de front du
donbass cramatte osc qui habite l'un des
centres les plus importants militaires
de l'armée ukrainienne
ce matin plusieurs déflagrations très
importantes ont été entendus là-bas et
encore plus au nord dans la ville de
kharkiv ville très importante en termes
de population qui se situe à quelques
kilomètres seulement de la frontière
russe cette ville s'est réveillée sous
des d'importantes déflagration qui iront
notamment créé la panique dans la
population beaucoup de bombardements
donc julien est ce qu'il ya des combats
directs entre les soldats russes et les
soldats ukrainien
alors le long de la frontière de la
ligne de front dont je vous parlais au
niveau du donbass il ya effectivement eu
des échanges de tirs entre l'armée
ukrainienne et les séparatistes
pro-russes voir les troupes russes là où
nous nous trouvions à marioupol donc sur
cette ville sa grande ville portuaire de
marioupol qui est la dernière ville
encore sous contrôle l'ukrainien
jusqu'aujourd'hui là il y a eu
effectivement des échanges de tirs entre
les deux camps est ce qu on nous a
rapporté et bien c'est d'après une
source du port de marioupol qui je le
précise n'est pas un port militaire mais
un port marchand et bien dans
l'après-midi des navires de guerre
russes se sont postés tout près de la
côte de marioupol en position d'attaqué
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de tirs
il n'y a pas eu d'ordre de type de
lancer des missiles sur la ville mais
selon la source mais la source du port
que avec qui nous avons parlé tout à
l'heure et bien en cas de tir l'armée
ukrainienne pourrait riposter merci
beaucoup julien chez ida ont direct de
hazard porridge à au sud-est de
l'ukraine